for all the people i asked hey were you
aware that there was a time when i was
trying to become a rapper and nobody
remembers it nobody knew i remember
being real remember
on that [ __ ] track we recorded was so
dope
it was so [ __ ] dope and just like
everything i did on the track was just
awful
but uh i didn't want to give you no
action
man
but he's doing a redemption album pretty
soon i'm trying to do it i'm trying to
like get organized to do uh some
redemption [ __ ] and like whatever just
make it fun and funny let me know
let me know dude i remember the track
that you and i recorded it was called if
i died today and the the whole like the
the whole gist of it was you know what
[ __ ] if i died today i killed it man
i'm stoked on on on what i accomplished
what i wasn't
and dude
ah why would that damn to the tournament
when steve's writing a rapper i i always
ask
i really just appreciated the [ __ ] out
of that thank you no worries
oh you know we're boys man i had to give
you that fire
all day
so cool when you're writing a song what
hits you first i know it's different for
everybody is it the lyrics or do you
have to hear the beat first
well some you know sometimes i'll get
ideas without the beat
and i'll just sort of mentally store
that away till till something comes
along that complements that idea like
rock superstar for instance that was in
my head
for um some years before we actually put
that out years yes
and aren't you worried you're gonna
forget it no well with something that is
like um
that strikes you heavy like you know you
know it's a good idea
you'll hold on to it and you'll remember
it and i was constantly like just
waiting for the right music
to happen you know mugs gave me many um
styles of of of beats and and and uh
you know
different options to write to you know
throughout all the albums you know and
what i wrote was basically
what i felt when i heard the music right
so that's the other way i write i when i
listen to the music the music speaks to
me as to
what i should be writing about or what
the concept about or or if it's just one
of those rapper brag brag the [ __ ] you
know brag about yourself
because there's that too right but we've
always tried to write cohesive songs
that mean something and [ __ ] like that
so i try to go where the beat takes me
you know i mean and but with with um
songs like rock stupid superstar and
there's a couple other ones but that was
obviously the biggest one that i held in
my head for a while um it wasn't until
mugs came with that particular
you know bed of music that you hear as
the song now
um where i felt like that's going to be
great for this idea here so i i did that
and at first it was just rap superstar
and don einer from columbia records he
was
you know um one of the one of the big
wigs in the industry period says
think you need some rock guitars on that
and we're like
oh
okay because you don't say no to donny
and mugs went and put the rock guitars
but then he had the foresight to put the
orchestral parts on it and made it like
you know it was like um
us
us being led zeppelin of hip-hop in that
and uh with that song that was our
cashmere yeah yeah you know what i mean
that's that's that's how we looked at it
like this is our cashmere it's cool and
so that that was one of the ones i had
in my head for years uh you know
other stuff i came up with on the fly
you know like like dr green thumb for
instance i got to the studio heard that
music
boom dr grantham and i made that song in
like 45 minutes something like that what
about the tunes it american psycho
was that with d12 yeah that was d12 that
was that [ __ ] track is so fire man
yeah they were killing it yeah they they
had the idea actually they they hit me
up and they were like hey we want you to
do this chorus
um
and they sort of give gave me an idea of
of what the song was about and then like
what they kind of wanted me to say but
like say it in my own
on my own terms in my own way and and so
that's that's what i did there and i
thought man that it is a [ __ ] tight
song when i hear it i i took it i i took
that and went and did a mixtape and put
a verse on it with with me and right
okay because i remember
like hearing it and then trying to look
for it and i was like i couldn't find it
yeah my
the one with my verse on it is is from
one of my gunslinger mixtapes that's
right yeah three volumes i had three
volumes uh there was uh gunslingers
there was gunslingers fistful of dollars
um a few dollars more and something else
it was all the clint eastwood right run
right that's what the problem was man
i'm glad we got to the bottom of that
because i got to dig up that track man i
love it so much oh yeah and then people
started hitting me like how did that not
make the d12 record i'm like well i did
it after yeah
they only asked me for for a chorus so
that's what i gave him if i had the
foresight to just
send the verse and be like hey i sent
this verse too yeah just in case right
remix style but i did i didn't do it i
didn't want to like impose it and then
you know having to be like i don't know
i know i what i did there but
i don't ever want to force my [ __ ] on
someone sure you know what i mean like
if you don't want it
cool
so instead of sending it i just held on
to it and used it for my mixtape and was
like [ __ ] nice go here dude it's
unbelievable it seems like the shorter
it takes you to write a song the bigger
the hit sometimes
sometimes you know like because you're
feeling
something in that moment and you have a
certain momentum it's coming from the
universe yes it's coming from somewhere
else it ain't coming from you when it's
like that it's coming from somewhere
else you know what i mean like for sure
with green thumb because with with green
thumb
um it was a sketch i wrote for the radio
show that i was hosting at the time
because we were doing a friday night mix
show eric bobo and myself called soul
assassins radio there's a soul
assassin's radio now from dj mugs on on
sirius xf
xm but before that it was on 92.3 the
beat fm here when that was
yeah theo on the radio yes and julio g
was also on this
this uh
station right so i would write sketches
so our mix show was like a saturday
night live with mixes because we would
do all the voice overs myself
bobo and our our uh partner quasi who
was our production guy and we'd get all
other artists to do voice-overs in these
sketches
and so we wrote one in a in the sense of
you know
it being like uh infomercials were big
at the time
and so i wrote an infomercial style
commercial for dr green thumb a
cultivator and
you know it was based off of me and my
boys growing weed because we we had
always done that we were pretty goddamn
good at it so you know
the nickname green thumb came from that
because you know you would see nurseries
out throughout los angeles or southern
california with that green thumb meaning
you're good at growing weed right so
that's
the idea popped off from that sketch
when i get to the studio and i hear that
beat
the sketch is in my mind on this beat
like oh [ __ ] this is the song and i i
just start going in
and uh we end up using that sketch to
that song
yeah you know what i mean um
so it all sort of just came together
like
out of nowhere but when i when i got to
the studio and i heard that beat
all the ideas for that song
along with that sketch start rolling out
and
45 minutes later it's laid and locked in
and i think i laid it at 10 in the
morning
on a [ __ ] thursday or something like
that and
muggs knew he was like
this is the [ __ ] right here b's gonna
[ __ ] slay this right here
and the funny thing about that song is
that
record company tried to get me to change
it they wanted me to do
switch the lyrics and make it more like
an insane in the brain part two or
something like it i said no i'm not
gonna change nothing we already got
insane in the brain and i'm like why
would i do that again
that would be redundant i'm sticking
with this and they're like ah radio
ain't gonna play it but okay it's a
great song
and i'm you know to this day i'm glad we
stuck to our guns because it became one
of our biggest songs
in terms of our our fan base just that
being one of the anthems and it was a
big a big hit in europe no less we were
tripping on that and uh it sort of made
its way into the pantheon of top
cypress song so like
just as a
you know to give you a
an indication right so
we play insane in the brain there's a
pop that happens with that right
people explode they go crazy it's nuts
mosh pits and you know
stage diving all that crap right
fast forward to now we do when we do
green thumb it's the same reaction
and they didn't think that was going to
happen they thought it was a waste of a
song and for me that that was like
it was a
something that happened
organically and it was
the it was the luck of the day because
who knew that that was going to become
my cannabis brand yeah i had no clue you
know
we always envisioned you know being able
to do this or that in the cannabis world
but we didn't know when we didn't know
how we didn't know what we were going to
do we just knew we'd be a part of it
somehow
but boom that song became
my entrance into
you know the the cannabis industry that
that's what was so special about that
song that that's why i say it came from
somewhere else because that song led me
somewhere else other than music it's
called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude